but in the quarter Parkman's got a hand
on it
James rained down the loose ball mr.
Pires kind of gave up
look like Orlando had that one it turns
into two easy points for Cleveland's
both up have just kind of run away from
it and this guy will do something with
it want to pass go
finishing shots like that turns it down
that's a wide open shot he's been
hitting all season long no reason to get
to the finals and turn it down Barnes
and Mozgov throws it down Ron James
going crazy how about the vision of
LeBron James already aware of the fact
that Bob's off with wide open does not
look little Magic Johnson in the final
miles off does the rest and then the
role players they'd asked him to support
wheezes shitbox toss to Jeff Huson from
the King
James with the bounce pass to ishes
belly up something in the brown the
brown with the bounce pass and Jefferson
throwing the hammer down it's really a
similar style as Richard Jefferson wall
mrs. Shumpert with a rebound inside two
minutes to go here's change lob for
Mozgov and so pretty gotta get in the
gym and just keep working on is buying
in the way big pass LeBron
[Applause]
[Music]
captain
pass and his prettiest help that night
that's a fastball right there take him
over to Progressive Field
two guys in the NBA Darrell tries to
draw the offensive foul nice pass again
and Thompson of finished another assist
for LeBron James he has five retire his
number at the end of the first James to
Thompson ball on a pass from LeBron
James LeBron James had nine Tristan
Thompson
trust your coach back door and a beauty
zone on the hop to JR Smith from LeBron
James Z shot was English but this is
something you saw all last year and this
is nice no-look time
and Tennessee 23 in his sleep
[Applause]
rook Pete and his wife Susan and then
the beautiful died he doesn't stay with
one team and I think he said good night
this is hunter inside Richard Jefferson
absolutely terrible huh a career-best
9.1 picking them apart like Corey Kluber
4329 James to the basket whips it out to
love free putter it's good
Kevin love with a huge three-pointer and
the next call timeout hook pass oversize
right into the shooting pocket of Kevin
Love I ask you Mark Jackson as one of
the great passers of all time
how many can make that pass in today's
game not many defensive in Chicago
anywhere together those thunderous dunks
necessary for deal with bullies that do
it the rim exquisite because Kyle Korver
right there he ain't right there he had
Calvin right there pass the ball between
the defenders legs normally the NBA's
most of proof where I was just under 20
again now plays a nice roll off the
bench for Indiana inside pull a pass
James with a step the system
absolutely Doris as they forced another
turnover two quick ones the Golden State
back door Kevin Love put the finish what
a pass by James small forward that's a
beautiful backdoor cut outstanding read
and pass by LeBron James look away it's
only one place he could have put it
James not going good job by Friday
tonight penetration here comes LeBron
James eyeballing some white shirts
Jimmy Osmond oh you know what that is a
seat at peanut butter to Jenni Ron is
past the ball better than he has this
year yes I mean in that bounce pass
right into the proper LeBron James
against cruisers wait for double again
don't look to Crowder thickest stop
there sometimes watching LeBron James
picking apart moment a nice drop pass
and crowd it with a good lay up Emily is
on the road
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you take a look at what understanding
the Brawn noon we're way it was and
supported plan that that even happened
he knew exactly where it was when he
made that pass a new wave was there he
saw Wade out of the corner of his eye
comes Collison stop the ball
good defense by two James Neal control
at three vultures to pick up Tristan
Thompson great job of moving and
understanding the situation he'd use his
eyes to open up WT down road for the dog
his fourth assist knew he would draw the
crowd and then net two minutes left in
the game
LeBron James that could be
time to pack faster unopened Tristan
Thompson but the good teams as we talked
to making with it how about this trick
amazing pass but if you could have seen
how rich Stan Van Gundy turns after
watching Eric Moreland loses God
defensively in the bronze vision is
unlike many we've seen it comes James
nice leaving through sit down
defense for a portion of beginning while
during Casey can talk all he wants I
think the biggest voice they're nice
from the belong to ad about the bounce
pass here LeBron James to the unibrow ad
used to see our own Isiah Thomas yeah
doing that
beautiful timeout taken by friken
damn Tony bends off Thomas tries to get
back to Smith missed it badly it caroms
out to James with a new shot clock he
might be a quarterback watch the ball
fake and then the little lean-to zou
such pretty start screen you know on
Yanis faintly because they'll get the
switch in your lap in this place they
run that play successfully a bunch of
times tonight James with the Knights
past until the playoffs roll around
we're not worried yet Airport now both
teams have two timeouts remaining and no
fouls to give James kicks it out to the
corner low for three
closing time Kevin
great pass by LeBron James down the
floor touchdown Spanish Jose with the
finish as high as 26 my speed his side
again he has had some magnificent passes
tonight
that's his ninth assistants keeping his
dribble and then just a beautiful left
hand wrap around
inside the angel is cutting off the book
nice pass to heart miss Laker team
they've been losing close games as
LeBron goes one-on-one got a bucket mean
he's had three passes tonight there's
work really been special he's coming
about with LBJ calls cameras showed
again he looks like he's gonna take the
shot good movement without the ball
again this time by Lonzo and the pun
says I thought if you're moving I see
you I'll get it to Lillard can't pay it
off James
[Applause]
player in the discussion for the best to
duel and this is an incredible path
dachshund its launch date neuron yes
Nick up wanted the G on the outlet but
the deal is being guarded Square Garden
crowd as he throws in the right pencil
wheelhouse for the easy assist to Kalki